Speaker 1: Hey, you know, if you're wondering
what happened to all the crime since November 8th,
you're actually bringing up a very interesting
question. Fox News stories about violent crime
are down 50% since the November 8th midterm
election. There's a very good research piece
from Media Matters Fox's coverage of violent crime
dropped after the midterms. Weekday violent crime
segments decreased by 50% in the week of the
election compared to the weekly average since
Labor Day. Are any of us surprised? In fact, Fox
News decreased stories about violent crime 63%.
Media Matters has the details. This is not unique,
I assure you, to Fox News. We all knew in the lead
up to the November 8th midterms that their stories
about violent crime, which of course ignore that.
By the way, stories about violent crime in what
they call Democrat cities not only ignore the
facts of, for example, on a crime rate basis,
Oklahoma is more dangerous than New York state and
on a crime rate basis. Both property and violent
crime. Oklahoma City is more dangerous than New
York City. Remember rates a lot more. People
live in New York City. Aside from the fact that
it's an absurd narrative and that most cities
in general are run by Democrats because more
Democrats tend to live in cities, we also know
that it's just a ploy. And I want to remind you,
I'm going to give you other examples, all of which
I have previously covered, because they do this
all the time. In 2014, it was Ebola. Remember the
guy who went bowling at Brooklyn Bowl? And at the
time I was like at Brooklyn Bowl the day after and
I was worried that I get Ebola. What's going on
anyway? 2014. We knew leading up to the midterms
that Ebola was being used by people like Rand
Paul stands out and many others just to criticize
Barack Obama. That's all that it was. They just
wanted to criticize Obama.
Speaker 3: Obama now.
Speaker 1: And even though there were like. Four
cases and the one person that died got Ebola
outside of the country, if I recall. Correct. I
mean, it was crazy. And the day after the 2014
midterms, no more talk about Ebola. And it never
came back. They never talked about it again.
Another example, this is a classic, the migrant
caravan coverage. This one was in 2018 leading
up to the 2018 midterms under Donald Trump. The
migrant caravans are on the way. They're coming.
They're coming here. And we know that. Migrant
caravans tell us, oh, there's an election coming
up. And of course, as is reported here, migrant
caravan coverage plummeted after the midterms
and indeed it did. And also a piece from Vox. Fox
News Barely Mentions Caravan. First morning after
midterms, Fox and Friends had been just ranting
and ranting and ranting about caravans day after
the midterms. They quite literally still have the
election results up on the screen. This was the
date. This was November. Sixth or seventh, 2018,
whenever, and they barely talk about it. We know
the story. We know exactly what they do. It's very
clear at this point. Remember not to follow it
and ask yourselves the question, not fall for
it. Ask yourself the question is this getting
coverage because it's important? Is this getting
coverage because it's accurate? Or is this getting
coverage because it serves a political goal or a
media goal which can often be creating fear and
titillating and scaring viewers? If you ask those
questions, you figure these out pretty quickly.